you have a certain limited time to plan
your mission
and you'll find so many creative ways
but at the end of the day you'll execute
the mission
even if you're not ready
[Music]
how are you doing i'm doing wonderful
michael it's friday
afternoon i'm feeling great how are you
i i am feeling just fine
i miss not seeing you on stanford campus
yeah
uh well they closed down campus so i
guess that we're not a long time ago
well roy
i'm excited to learn more about your
journey and share your journey
you know we've gotten to know each other
quite well over these past this past
year as you were finishing your business
degree at stanford graduate school of
business
uh quite an experience i'm sure which i
can't wait to hear more about but
but you have such a phenomenal life
experience and all these
different things that you've done
transitioning from
a leader in the idf to intel to studying
in the technion
so so many different things all the way
leading up to stanford that i'd love to
just
talk about your life and perhaps touch
on the on the different events
and draw some uh some nuggets that you
now take with you
on your entrepreneurial journey how does
that sound cool sounds
great roy who are you
who am i roy i'm a 34 years old
israeli entrepreneur born and raised in
ebony uda and i think that being israeli
is a big part of my life
why do you say that why do i say that
being israeli
means you connect yourself with a
country with your jewish heritage
you live it you born as an individual
but you
experience your country and so
such big intensities uh from serving
your country
and also being pissed about politics i
think that it's
unique being israeli um of course
100 so talk to me a little bit about
about your experience at stanford
business school you started two years
ago you're coming from israel
you mentioned that it was almost a life
dream to go there right
yeah so stanford business school was a
life dream of
uh about six years that i planned to go
to stanford gsb
and what's incredible about stanford is
that you interact with amazing people
you're getting inspired
on daily basis you have the professors
it's really different from the israeli
experience of studying in college
the professors know you they'll have
coffee with you hopefully they'll invest
in you
in the future but they're very very
generous with their time and knowledge
so stanford is incredible uh the people
that bring there everybody breathes
entrepreneurship you get inspiration
from
silicon valley as just this is the place
to be
for an entrepreneur i think and okay
so now now i what i would love to do is
to talk about different parts of your
life and the different experiences that
from there
because just before we started this call
you mentioned that looking back and
reflecting on these
different experiences good and bad
experiences you've you've
accumulated these nuggets that now as
you're creating your startup and you're
and now
the founder of a startup and stealth
mode
now you're using these experiences to
move forward so i i'd love to
to open the floor and let you guide me
through these
these different adventures that you've
had cool so i'll mention that i'm
working on a startup right now it's an
ai powered startup and it's in stealth
mode so i can't talk about it too much
but it's my second startup and
i didn't understand where the resilience
and not losing hope came from how the
hell am i waking up in the morning and
grinding on getting
clients getting validation from
investors and getting rejected on daily
basis but also continuing moving forward
until i get the success from every
distress
and it brought me to i realized that
basically being an entrepreneur
uh the entrepreneurial thing in me was
very much influenced by my military
service
so uh i had a very broad
military service starting from uh
pilot school and then i went to be a
tank fighter and then an intelligence
officer and one of the intelligence
officer positions crazy all right that's
just crazy from
my list from the pilot academy the one
of the most prestigious areas
in the idf going to be to to be in a
tank which is an extraordinary
experience all the way to be an
intelligence officer another position
that is
sought after by so many people going
into the military sorry but continue i'm
just i'm
impressed by by the variety of
experiences that you've had
thank you so when my first military uh
officer position was in uh a commander
unit
golani and instead golani
that one of the values is you'll get
a mission a certain mission it will seem
unrealistic
right you perform it but you will go and
do it
and you have a certain limited time to
plan your mission
and you'll find so many creative ways
but at the end of the day you'll execute
the mission
even if you're not ready right and that
was very very inspiring for me
you find out in many cases and every
night
that you don't have the solution yet you
need to march forward
you need to perform the task and
sometimes just by
having the hope that everything will be
fine and
you'll just go and do it by that you
only
you did like 90 of the job right right
uh
not to say that these are dangerous
missions and entrepreneurship is way not
like this but that mentality
really taught me a lot uh moving forward
today
another thing is that you go to a
military mission
and you don't really have all the
intelligence you don't really have all
the information about
the other side to execute the mission
but yet you go and do that you take the
risk
and a lot of many times uh wherever you
work
somewhere or whether you lead a company
you need to cope with uncertainty
you won't have all the answers you won't
have all the information to take
a calculated decision but this is what
why people
uh trust us this is why people pay us
salaries
so i i learned that uh
i guess instead of golani when you look
at the
at yourself as an entrepreneur now you
mentioned that there are various
experiences that you've taken lessons
from there and now you're
implementing them in your day-to-day
life as an entrepreneur whether it be
rejection or leadership or
vision or creativity so i'd love to to
to get more insight into
what are the areas that that you've
gained this inspiration for
yeah so what i really uh enjoy at the
end of the day
uh when i'm working with people my
co-founder the people that we work with
is not forgetting that there are people
i really it's really important for me
to talk to people even go to small
details
and that was another lesson taught by
another position that i had in my
military service
so i'll tell you that the journey of
being a commander in the idf
was very very special when you interact
with your soldiers
so i i've led around 80 soldiers in my
military service
and as a commander you are sometimes
their best friends sometimes their enemy
you are representing the system a system
that
kind of like forces people to serve in
the military not everybody wants to be
there not everybody is an officer who
wants to volunteer
not everything gets a fit to their
careers to be a leader
and these special relationships that you
have
sometimes you encounter when in
situations where
you are a psychologist to a suicidal uh
suicidal soldier or whether you are
in a couple therapy if your soldiers are
dating each other
you're a social worker if the background
of your soldier is
from a very uh right situation you go to
their places and see
how they live sometimes they are a
pillow
because the military missions when you
need to sleep somewhere
uh you have like a map
i think that what you're touching on
here which is very very true
the idf is a compulsory service which
brings with it
a lot of the challenges of what it means
to lead within a within a program like
this where every person
and every person enlists and then
naturally when the whole organization is
very young because
the majority of the organization is 18
to 21 year olds
you have very young leaders so at the
age of 19 you get a team of
eight to ten people and say okay welcome
you are now their
their sibling their parent their
psychologist a social worker
and you have to now all of a sudden
understand what that means and
and i can totally relate to these
lessons that you're sharing about
but what a how are you learning to lead
by example and to be a commander that
way
what is the now that you've gone through
stanford business school as well and
and the school where a lot of the
classes are about leadership and about
management and and how to successfully
lead a business
talk to me a little bit about the
differences between leading a team in
the army
rather than leading a team perhaps at a
startup or in a business and you've also
gotten a chance to work at a few
companies so you also can
have that experience as well yeah so
leading people
by example is definitely one of these
and also understanding that at the end
of the day
these are people ambitions you need to
understand what is the motivation behind
the people
even in your startup everybody has their
own
need to give an input need to impact
they have their own passions
and learning what is their motivation is
like the best leadership skill that i
learned in the military another thing is
working as a team
so in many ways the social
connections that teams have are really
kind of like perpetuating energy
and commitment to the company yeah
and i think that it's sometimes
overlooked
um because people want to work and they
have their
work-life balance uh in the military you
kind of like
live within work and the people that
you're stuck with you're working with
them
and you go to your room and you stay
with them in the same room
so everywhere that i go i
try to bring that team cohesiveness
and trying to kind of lower the guards
of
people so they can feel comfortable how
do you do that
how do you lower guards of people so
that your teammates can be comfortable
so i i believe that encouraging open
discussion
so we uh i know that you wear
an officer in the israeli defense forces
as a intelligence officer
and we have a big set a big story about
uh not saying
what you have in mind you need to always
say what you have in mind if you think
that it's important
so you always need to encourage a
discussion if it's relevant to how we
work
and what are we working on and so always
raise like always encourage people to
talk
to be open about these things we don't
want to hold any aggression towards
the goal or the teeth so this is super
important
second thing is that we need to stay and
work until we
until work is done because eventually
um sometimes we need to deliver and some
of that military experience brought me
to understand that i need to
stay with my employees and support them
and my team which is something that you
see in the military all the time
right right and kind of like
supporting them is kind of create a
synergy that
they feel more motivated they feel
supported
and they're not alone so 100
no yeah that's i i i completely resonate
with what you're saying talk to me a
little bit about the
about the gsb experience so you
mentioned a little bit about the
entrepreneurship side of it about the
social side of it
i'd love to really hear uh because i you
know i i haven't gone through the gsb
myself and and so many other friends
we all really want to but it's it's a
little it's a little far
and while we hope to get in one day you
now have the opportunity to share with
me
having just finished it so talk to me a
little bit about
the the good the bad and the ugly the
good the bad and the ugly
the good is an incredible open community
so the gsb is very special by
people are uh encouraged to share
be vulnerable and and support each other
that's wonderful we have once a week we
have two classmates doing a talk
30 minutes dedicated all to them sharing
their life story
and you see these people in class and
they are
super smart and then you go to talk and
you
hear incredible stories of growth facing
adversity and people
are incredible uh second thing about
this university that is really not
competitive
which is good so we have a great
non-disclosure you don't feel any
competition
people are just helping each other which
i think is interesting because it's
extremely competitive to get into the
acceptance rate is one of the lowest
in the world yet the second you're in
you're a part of this community that
you're saying it's not it's not
competitive right
it's true and you know it's the highest
percentage at the highest
uh it's the lowest it's the lowest
percentile
of getting in right right programs
and this great non-disclosure
allows people to just like not think
about race
just study be focused on their friends
and right together collaborate take
risks it's encourage you to
do mistakes because eventually you will
graduate
right so you mentioned a few times also
to me outside of this is that the
part of the magic of the gsb is if you
have all these people who are coming
from extremely different backgrounds
you're coming in
as a as a as an officer from the idea if
you have people coming in
after they've ran businesses around the
world or have had different adversities
that they've overcome and when you come
into an institution that they're no
grades are involved
you each have your own personal grade
but the goal at the end is to graduate
together as a community
and to build relationships that will
spend way beyond the campus but
in the real world and in the business
world right exactly
uh i will move to the bed
the thing is that it's only two years
it's only two years i love that it's
only two years so it's kind of it's a
paradise for education
you're getting inspired every day it's a
tremendous growth like
i was basically half vacationing uh
traveling with friends and still i feel
like i boosted my career and grew
grew as an entrepreneur and only two
years i wish it was
cheaper and uh and
longer i guess i guess was it worth was
it worth working for six years
to get in for this two-year experience
i believe so i'm pretty like biased as
you know i put a lot of money in this
program too
um so you have to believe that
it gives you something but looking
backwards two years ago
coming from israel even with my fluent
english i didn't know
how it would grow me to
to be where i am today i feel
comfortable fundraising now
with top pcs collaborating and selling
my products to clients yeah
yeah that boosted my confidence
greatly and uh so i'm grateful for that
also
this community is incredible yep rich
knowledge
so much grace people are like helping
all the time
um which i i think it's really really uh
i wish my alma mater uh
technion would be more like this that
people would collaborate more
the alumni network it's like we have so
much time in technion
and they still haven't picked up about
building a community
that helps uh helps their members
so i'm really i think the interesting
thing is that in israel the equivalent
of the experience the
community experience of the of a
university is your army unit because
when we go to
the average bar in tel aviv you don't
really ask hey where did you go to
school you asked hey which unit did you
serve in
in the u.s obviously it's the first
question and so i think that there
is it's so interesting to see two
different you know communities two
different countries two different
incredible countries
with with people growing up in different
different ways and but at the end
it's all about the community and it's
all about the people
one thing you mentioned to me which i
i'd love to bring up uh you asked me
you told me well that you know every
really amazing ceo has their schtick
they have their thing and you ask me
michael what is going to be your thing
well roy i'm going to turn the question
to you because this is about you what is
it what is jurgen what is your
thing as the ceo cool uh
so i'll go wild and i say that i'm going
to be the jungle ceo
so every ceo is crazy my offices is
going to be all about nature i'm going
to have trees
i'm going gonna have animals jumping
around monkeys tigers
running forth of course and i'll be you
know elon musk is the
space guy i'm going to be nature guy
what are you going to be
i have no idea yet i have to i'm gonna
see how yours plays out and then i'll
make my decision
and no but you have i mean you've also
really inspired me to be more conscious
about
about my eating habits and and
meditation and you're it's not just
about nature you're
really you i think one thing that i've
gotten to know about you over these past
over this past year is this idea of like
being of inner collectiveness and and
inner calmness and really
being in touch with who you are so i
want to thank you for for bringing that
to my attention because
both of us reflect often on how driven
we are and how much time we spend on
on on racing to something yet
at the same time you're very conscious
on on also your introspection and
and taking the time to really reflect
and i really appreciate that you brought
that
reflection into my life because these
are not mutually exclusive racing to
something
and being happy internally and being
satisfied
roy i want to thank you for being so
generous with your time before we leave
i need three words that you would use to
describe yourself
okay jews
entrepreneurial israeli
and loving because i have a lot of love
in me
a hundred percent i can testify from the
from the past year
watching you both in the classroom and
also outside in the social scene
it resonates i can't wait to see the
incredible things that you do and
be part of each other's journeys so
thank you very very much for taking the
time to be here
thank you mike